we can ask our next guest who i've known
for a very long time and this
is why one of the many reasons why i
love him and i i love having him on
because you could see here um i i
got this on father's day best dad ever
and i i've apologized to all the other
dads
but this gentleman if anybody's going to
give me a run for
for my money i mean he wrote a beautiful
book about his relationship with his
wife and their children
and he's given his daughter
opportunities in the television business
that few people have true i want to talk
about best dad ever
possibility it's my friend from espn
adam schefter how are you shifting
from one great dad to another rich happy
father's day happy birthday happy
everything right back gotcha
right back at you how are you doing
groundhog day rich
never thought we celebrated over the
course of a full year but that's what
we're doing
you you're hearing i got you babe every
day waking up and uh
going about your business pretty much
what are you saying
it's really uh amazing like there is
nothing on the calendar in the summer
and i have no idea you know if there's
anything to look forward to at all other
than
training camp opening yes um
we'll get to that there's no weekend
trips there's no outings planned there's
no
concerts no sporting no nothing well now
hold on a second and and then know
nothing i think includes haircuts when
was the last time you got your hair cut
no it's funny you should say that
richard okay because what happened was
obviously the last time i got my hair
cut you can remember these things and i
keep a journal which helps me along the
process but i
got my hair cut on friday march 13th
leading into free agency
okay that was the last time that i got a
full cut now during the pandemic when we
were
sheltering in place my son pulled out
a razor and would shave my sides
okay and that was about the extent of my
haircuts for three months until
father's day on sunday when it also
happened to be my son's 20th birthday
okay and i took him for a haircut were
the first people in a shop that opened
in new york it was like phase three
they just begun allowing people in a few
days earlier
we still didn't know whether we felt
comfortable doing it we went
and i got my hair i decided because my
hair grew longer i'm like you know what
i'm just going to leave it long i got to
cut the
sides and so i was doing a hit on espn
on monday one of my producers text me
like when you're getting that haircut
i'm like i got it yesterday i know that
i got my hair cut
so it still looks a little bit longer
and bushy and unkempt and
certainly not the way that i've worn it
but you know what yes i don't really
care rush
you know i don't care because if you're
going to keep letting
it go long and have your son only shave
the sides there could be some mike gundy
uh coming your way you know what i'm
saying like if it means
throwing a mullet in the back that's
what it means right what am i going to
say
if i've got enough hair to grow a mullet
i'm going to grow it there you go adam
schefter business in front party in the
back here on the rich eisen show right
now
uh all right let's get into it adam you
i'm sure you're asked you might you
might be the one recipient of this
question
uh leading leading the entire nation
other than i guess roger goodell uh
is there going to be football in 2020
what are you not to turn you into an
epidemiologist or anything but what are
you
what are you hearing and sensing right
now
rich i would say that it depends on who
you ask right okay and i think that my
answer to that question would be when i
speak to people on teams they're they're
nervous they're uneasy they're anxious
they're concerned when i speak to other
people
who are near the top of the nfl food
chain
they are convinced that there's gonna be
football now
again all that tells me is that the
league is determined
to get this season in to get the 16
games in
all those things like that whether that
can actually happen during the course of
the year without outbreaks of the virus
no one can predict right they're going
to try to pull off something that
i think sean mcvay himself has said
when we are asked to social distance and
not
be in close proximity to one another and
not breathe on one another like this
sport
goes against everything that we are
being told to do in society today
and so can they get through that i
i'm not smart enough scientifically
medically to predict that i can tell you
that there are people on teams that are
anxious and concerned
and there are people in and around the
league
that are convinced that they're going to
have football this season convinced like
not even a hesitation oh yeah
there's football like one guy texted me
last week
when the fouchy news came out where he
said i don't know if the nfl could get
this done
this season without a bubble and this
particular individual texted me
there will be football this year without
any hesitation
and so you believe what you want from
that
but that is how i read it concern
anxiety
nerves but a belief going in
that they're going to do everything they
can and will to pull it off what about
any players that
uh you might have come across because
you know you heard i'm sure malcolm
jenkins what he said on cnn as he's been
hired
um he's been hired there as an analyst
um calling it a non-essential business
and for him to
to to come he needs to be assured best
he can and i know that the league
mentioned yesterday through their chief
medical officer dr alan sills that
there's going to be an aggressive
testing regimen what are you hearing him
from players right now
adam what was interesting to me there
rich is that
a few weeks back i had james connor my
podcast and you would think that if
anybody would be concerned
it would be him he has a pre-existing
medical condition
you would think somebody like that would
be alarmed and i can only infer
that his feelings are representative of
most players feelings not all
not all but many and when i asked him if
he was concerned at all
he acted like what is there to be
concerned about no
i'm playing football no issues and i
thought that was interesting because if
like i said anybody had any reason to be
uneasy it would be him and he
didn't have the slightest bit of
hesitation so if james connor feels that
way
that tells me that the majority of
players feel that way again there are
going to be
cases like malcolm jenkins and there are
going to be people who are concerned and
nervous
my wife is a type 1 diabetic i we
live every day highly aware of
everything that we're doing everywhere
we're going
and trying to make sure we do the best
job we can to
not go anywhere mask up when we do do
the right thing
and what's amazing to me is to hear the
various viewpoints in our
country some of them blow me away like
i mean i i just can't believe that
people some people would be so defiant
to not wear a mask everybody gets to do
what they want free country but it's
to me just a basic human consideration
of your fellow man and why somebody
would not do that to me
is unbelievable uh plus one adam um
uh i i fully agree and and for
fans um of the nfl or sports in general
who say screw it i'm not wearing a mask
you know i don't believe
what the science shows um
well if you're not masking up guess what
there's a chance there's no nfl
i i mean that's that's a fact there's a
chance that there's no excuse
rich if everybody mess up the virus
doesn't go anywhere if the virus doesn't
go anywhere
we get to have sports in school and
activities and all the things we want
right so why would you not mask up like
it's just it's it's it's it's amazing to
me like
i just can't understand it and again
i guess and we're seeing it now right
like i live in new york
and we went through three very difficult
months
and now we're seeing cases spike where
there really weren't
cases and instances before so these
people who doubted the virus
didn't believe in the violence like i i
was talking to somebody yesterday was in
my house
um an electrician he came to work on
some uh
like some things some issues anyway he
said to me it's
a media creation now
i i don't know what to say to that like
i i don't believe that's right
but that's what he and many others
believe
that it's a media creation which
again i hear that i go oh okay
um if even if you think it's a media
creation then why would you not wear a
mask
like he wasn't wearing a mask you know
and it's his and it's his job to put a
light bulb over somebody's head too
you think it would go off well you know
i mean i i i
you know adam i i i don't understand it
it is something that this country is
grappling with all we need to see is how
our country's dealing with it and other
countries that have gotten through it
yeah yeah but rick's right there okay
that's a great example
there are some countries where basically
the virus
seems to be going away if not gone
correct some countries have done a great
job
masking up sheltering in place doing
what's asked of them
i i'm not getting polish this has
nothing to do with this is
basic human decency basic
common sense why is it that some
countries
the virus is just whittled away to where
it's essentially a non-factor
yet in our country of the highest amount
of coronavirus cases
that we've had since this virus began
spreading
and here we are towards the end of june
uh about a a month away
from when nfl training camps are
supposed to open a couple more minutes
left with with adam schefter here
on on the rich eisen show let's get into
i guess
uh a couple of football items
the jamal adams situation your thoughts
on
uh i i think it's much ado about nothing
because the jets have two years of
contractual control it's a lot of
wishful thinking on
the part of a player who i adore uh and
think is terrific
how do you think this plays out adam
it's been a one-way street rich
now again all the noise has been coming
from the jamal adams side
that he wants to trade here are the
teams and that's great and
we all can agree the guy is a tremendous
player he's an unbelievable player one
of the best young
players in the national football league
but just because he wants to be traded
doesn't mean that the jets are going to
oblige him
and the jets in this particular case the
cba is set up
to where players are at a disadvantage
in trying to force a trade like that
like if he doesn't report to camp on
time
he loses this as an accrued season he's
one season further away from for agency
and he can say well i'm not playing for
the jets
well then they could just sit on him and
if that's the case
the jets probably win the standoff in
the end so
to me in any cases the two sides have to
work together to figure it out whatever
it is to make
each other happy the system is weighted
in favor of the team the player has a
lot to overcome
but i will say that in recent seasons
we've seen the players seize
more and more control more and more
power and enforce that
just see khalil mack jaylen ramsey many
of the others
that have forced their way out of town
with a trade and maybe that is the jamal
adams strategy
but the jets are not
just going to go peacefully and i know i
continue to be stopped and just as often
as i'm asked
[Music]
where's jamal adams being traded like i
don't know that he's being traded
like it's going to be up to some other
team to really step forward
and the jets to be convinced that they
would trade them and i don't know how
many
teams that are out there that would be
willing to mortgage the farm and then
pay the player
and then do all those things you could
say well jamal adams with the furry
wouldn't
do the contract right away no that is
correct but eventually
a year from now he's going to want to be
paid and you have to pay him like that
so
again it's it's great to talk about
it creates great father you can ask
about it we can discuss it
but the fact of the matter is to me up
to date as great a player as he is it's
been a one-way street
and now dak has signed his tender adam
we all know it's a deadline league the
deadline is july 15th any chance it gets
complicated for the cowboys and dak or
definitely for the cowboys
by a desean watson or even patrick
mahomes
signing that makes this even more
difficult for dallas
i i think that's one of those cases
where that's already been factored into
the equation
okay and so the situation to me is
complicated and it is complex
and dak prescott if he's willing to bet
on himself and so far he has been
can play this out and see it through to
where
to me he puts himself in position
to get a
incredible contract like if he just
wants to go year to year
right now wow and that's tough on the
cowboys because then you could be
walking away
or leaving parting with your quarterback
at any given moment in any given year
and good luck trying to find another
quarterback that's a tough thing to do
and so i will not be surprised if the
two sides can't figure out a deal
i think dallas in my mind it's easy for
me to say this but i
i think dallas once the guy long-term
wants to avoid it uh
they might be best served going down to
the four years that dak wants as opposed
to the five that they want i know they
want five but
in this particular case isn't it worth
reducing it one year
to make sure that you've got the guy
because if not i don't think he's going
to sign if he's not signing that means
they got to franchise him next year at
37.7 if they can't get a deal done then
the franchise take the next year is 54
million and so dak prescott is that
close to becoming a true
unrestricted free agent at the age of 26
27 years old
and there aren't many quarterbacks
entering the prime of their career at
that position
who entered the free agent market kirk
cousins did it and had his whole
contract guaranteed you could just
imagine
what would be at stake if dak prescott
could get himself to the market
before he sent adam into his uh friday
ask him the poll question
christopher all right adam who is the
winner of the rex ryan annual
winner of the nfl off season award bills
bucks cardinals
dolphins bucks i mean that's easy you
get tom brady get the greatest
quarterback of all time you
automatically win the award it's like
steve kerr and judd bushler driving to
the stadium after michael jordan
returned from playing baseball as you
said in them
one of those movies about michael jordan
and one of the players asked the other
one you think
that michael jordan will start tonight
and the other one said generally
speaking if there's a statue of you
outside the stadium you start
and i think it's true with tom brady
generally speaking if you sign tom brady
yes during all season you get that rex
ryan off season award
well i didn't even include the i i said
the 49ers
uh adam i love what they did for uh
sending deforest buckner
uh for a first round i know but they
they draft ken law they sign armstead
they sign jimmy ward they sign
kyle shanahan they um they
they drafted ayuk uh and they they were
six minutes from winning the super bowl
you know brady and gronk uh and
you know obviously re-signing peter paul
and re-signing sue
and and tagging barrett i mean just to
name a few and then their draft is
excellent too
uh they didn't make the super bowl last
year we still don't know that's my point
on that front again i think the bucks
win the offseason the 49ers had a really
impressive offseason and did a lot of
things that they wanted to do
you didn't even mention trent williams
by the way that's true i that i did
earlier
trent williams right i mean the whole
leader wanted the whole league wanted
him
great player great player and then you
put him
in that offense the way they run the
football oh
that's right that's what i'm saying all
right adam love you brother
love you rich right back thanks for
watching happy belated birthday father's
day
groundhog day everything right back at
you take you take care adam that's adam
schefter
only thing bigger than his knowledge and
information is his heart that is a real
fact
look you see del tufo is like saying a
jewish goodbye to him right now
are you having a jewish goodbye with him
put him back on real quick hang on hang
on
adam adam you haven't are you having a
jewish goodbye with del tufo
right here yeah i'd love to go way back
you go way back i mean adam i told you
the story i was saying at the brockman
the first time adam met me
yeah at the hall of fame yeah he comes
up to me thinking i'm like a producer of
something important at the nfl
and he's like and he's like shaking my
hand he's nice to me whatever and i'm
like adam i just do the audio do you
remember do you remember this
adam i i i i i kind of do rich
[Laughter]
well he's got also like you probably you
probably put it in a journal and made
notes about it like
10 seconds later that's what adam does
he thought i was like i'm like i'm just
the audio guy i'm not that important
but you already were important i don't
care what you're doing i know i love
that
adam's one of the best you are i mean
all right
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here